le
wendy gagnant donc moi je concours dans
la catégorie l'avait mis création
d'emplois mais je crois que c'est pas la
bonne catégorie
donc je suis plutôt dans l'insertion en
fait je suis maquilleuse donc depuis un
an et demi
donc je travaille pour un grand groupe
de parfumerie en étant prestataires de
services donc en fait le maquillage dans
tout le monde connaît mais souvent c'est
assimilé à l'esthétique donc je suis pas
esthéticienne je suis vraiment
spécialisé dans le maquillage c'est pour
sublimer en fait les beautés
réunionnaise de n'importe quel type et
on peut ça peut être un homme une femme
j'ai déjà maquillé des hommes des femmes
voilà ça peut être dans le mode la
beauté ça peut être pour une pub ça peut
être pour un mariage ça peut être donc
tout on va dire toutes sortes de
prestations qui peut exister où on a
besoin d'être maquillée derrière voilà
ça peut aider une personne à se voit là
à se sentir mieux dans sa peau ça peut
aider des personnes à camoufler des
petits des petits défauts et moi je suis
là pour le maquillage itinérante donc je
fais toute l'île voilà après j'aime mon
métier j'aime tout ce qui touche à la
création donc vous voit on voit pas tous
les jours les mêmes mille visages on va
pas tous les jours les mêmes gens donc
moi c'est ce que j'aime dans mon métier
et j'avais envie de faire partager ça en
fait il faut dire que je suis pas du
tout ici de semis de là à la base moi
j'ai un dss de communication option
journalisme
donc ya pas du tout lien avec
l'esthétique j'ai eu l'opportunité en
fait de rencontrer le grand patron d'une
parfumerie est en fait il m'a débauche
il m'a dit voilà est-ce que vous voulez
être notre maquillage officiel
pour ce groupe là donc j'ai dit oui mais
sachant que je voulais pas être employés
voulaient vraiment est à mon compte et
du coup il a accepté mes conditions et à
côté je peux faire quand même d'autres
choses dot
je suis pas que lié à ce groupe là je
suis vraiment pour moi et c'est ce qui
me plaît d'être libre en fête
bonjour je me présente pas d'olivier
j'habite à s'attendrir donc ça fait un
an et un mois que j'ai créé mon
entreprise c'est services à la personne
donc ménage et repassage à domicile donc
le ménage c'est beaucoup à la vapeur et
des huiles essentielles et du vinaigre
blanc
donc c'est un ménage écologie je ramène
tout mon matériel chez la personne donc
que soit ma machine quoi aspirez et qui
nettoie même temps à la vapeur qui
nettoie aussi les baies vitrées les
sanitaires les canapés et délits on va
dire ça fait dix ans que dans la
restauration en métropole je suis arrivé
ici j'ai on va dire pendant les dix ans
de la restauration je faisais leur
passage pour mes clients
on va dire des clients assez aisé on va
dire d'état américain donc je fais l
leur passage est aussi un peu le
nettoyage de leur chambre
donc même si vite et on va dire maître
d'hôtel ont fait un peu tout dans
l'hôtel
donc voilà c'est une passion le ménage
cuisine et le repassage c'est une
passion que voilà que j'ai depuis
longtemps et je dis pourquoi pas
pourquoi les autres qui réussissent
pourquoi pas moi donc je me suis lancé
et pour l'instant ça marche on est là
pour leur faire un petit peu de pub on
va dire
c'est un petit plus c'est un trentenaire
passé et on va dire c'est grâce à vous
si on peut avoir pour des clients tels à
mieux créer des emplois surtout avec la
crise en ce moment précis c'est possible
crée des emplois et est grande et la
société bonjour je m'appelle christine
filet je représente un club sur le
département de la réunion depuis un an
maintenant qu'ils s'appellent
l'invitation le club existe en métropole
depuis trois ans le concept est de créer
des partenariats avec des établissements
hôteliers restaurateurs loisirs
bien-être et par la suite de pouvoir
faire bénéficier de ces offres aux
membres dont qui ont la carte
l'invitation alors la carte l'invitation
elle est valable 12 mois de date à date
elle est nominative et l'avantagent
c'est qu'elle est valable dans les dom
tom et en france métropolitaine
le petit plus c'est que le concept se
développe aussi en belgique au
luxembourg et bientôt en espagne ce qui
permettra d'avoir un côté international
donc à mon niveau ce serait de relancer
à un tout petit peu comme je dis à mon
niveau
l'économie touristique je suis dans la
phase de création d'un site local qui
mettra donc en avant ces établissements
un petit livret qui mettra aussi en
avant donc sur un support papier nos
partenaires est vraiment de diffuser un
maximum le concept l'invitation alors la
grosse différence c'est qu'avec une
seule carte
je peux voyager partout et je peux
bénéficier d'offres un acheté un offert
c'est le principe avec les différents
concurrents je ne pense pas que ce soit
le cas je sais que si je vais en
métropole demain dans telle ou telle
région
je regarde sur leur site internet le
site internat qui est national
voilà je réserve auprès d'un hôtel ou
d'un restaurant c'est le petit plus ce
que je pense du concept l'invitation